TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Bring voice control, natural
language understanding, Google
Smarts, and more to your devices
using the Google Assistant SDK.
The developer preview
is now available.
Get the sample code and
videos from the post linked
in the description below.
Businesses that use the
Google My Business API
can now publish their
entire menu to Google.
Itemized with descriptions,
photos, and prices, making it
frictionless for their customers
to view their menus on Google.
Screenshots and sample
code are on the post.
Quizzes and Google Forms help
teachers automate testing
and get feedback
to students faster
by having forms check responses
against correct answers
automatically.
And now you can create these
quizzes programmatically
with app script.
Screenshots and code
are on the post.
Beginning in
October 2017, Chrome
will show the not secure
warning in two more situations--
when users enter data on an
HTTP page and on all HTTP pages
visited in incognito mode.
Which makes it a
good time for me
to say HTTPS is easier and
cheaper than ever before.
And it enables both best
performance the web offers
and powerful new features that
are too sensitive for HTTP.
Check out our setup
guides to get started.
Everything's linked
from the post.
You can now define
and run a GRPC API
and serve both GRPC
and JSON HTTP 1.1
to your clients using
Google Cloud Endpoints.
More details are on the post
linked in the description
below.
Please like and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of the Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]